what's going on everyone really pumped
to tell you one of my
strongest and most powerful tactics in
persuasion
that allows you to use integrity to
increase the trust in your prospects
by owning all of your deficiencies with
a single statement
all right so uh many times if you're
thinking about how you're selling
someone
the degree to which they will buy is
directly correlated with how much they
trust you
especially in a b2b scenario where if i
said hey for every dollar you give me
you'll make 10 back
if i if someone truly believed that then
every single person would buy from me
right because there's no logical reason
not to
so underpinning that is whether they
believe me or not and that could be
within the context whether they believe
in themselves
versus the system versus the world
there's other sub beliefs there but
fundamentally
if those three things are aligned and
they truly believe in their core
then they're going to buy which is the
same reason that when you have a
referral that gets on the phone with you
it's so easy to close them because the
person who referred them has already
imbued you with trust they've already
vouched for you
and so the person comes in with sky high
trust and really just you just need to
get out of their way so they can make
the purchase
and so i learned this tactic from eminem
in eight mile
um and uh you can see it at work and
i'll give you a couple of prominent
examples
but it's using the word but all right
and this is the concept of
damaging admission which is probably my
single favorite
uh technique to use in persuasion
because
it allows me to be even more honest than
i otherwise would be
in a world of like charlatans where
people are always making huge promises
and making huge claims and never kind of
being real and authentic with people
you stick out like a sore thumb in a
good way right and so let me give you a
statement really quickly
um and then we're gonna i'm gonna show
you how to how to reverse it in order to
make it more persuasive
so let's say i said um i'm going to make
you
uh you're going to make a ton of money
if you work with me but it's going to be
a ton of work
there's going to be hundreds of hours of
videos you're going to have to go
through
um there's five hours a day that you're
going to have to spend
you know to execute each of the things
that i'm going to tell you to do
right what happens is in that statement
i directed your attention
to all of the things that you're going
to have to do right
now if you noticed it was positive
statement
but negative statement now if you
reverse these things
and go negative statement but positive
statement
the butt acts as an amplifier for the
second half let's try it on
listen if you sign up for gym launcher
you sign up to work with me
you're gonna have to go through hundreds
of hours of videos you're gonna have to
take five hours a day
you know to work and do these things but
you're gonna make more money than ever
in your life the thing is is that
but and then the statement when i say
something negative
if i was on a date for example and i was
trying to persuade a young lady
you know back in the day before i was
married i might say something like
listen
you know sometimes i have a temper um i
can be
i can be short at times i don't have a
ton of time
to get dedicated to a relationship right
now because my business is taking up the
majority of my time
but i'm absolutely fantastic in bed
right if i said something like that the
thing is is the more negatives i can
say in the beginning the more believable
the thing that i say right afterwards is
right and so if i own all of my
negatives which is why i love this
because be truthful in the things that
you're saying that are negative and the
more true they are
and the more damaging they are the more
believable the thing that comes after
the sentence
all right and so the way to use but
because everything that happens here
after the word but is amplified
all right and everything
that is before the word but is
diminished
so you have so the good thing is you can
actually control
where your prospect's attention is going
so this is where we're
where we're directing them it's after
the word but and so
i do this sometimes um you know the word
because is actually really similar too
to this in a different way i'll use it
in another video
but uh if if i say something really
horrible
um i'm trying to think of something else
uh
let's see here uh i'm i'm really hard to
live with um
i i absolutely do no house chores
whatsoever but whatever i say right now
is something that you're going to
believe
right and so when you use this to your
advantage
and you weave this into your copy
especially as you get closer to your
call to actions
people will believe you and
fundamentally this is what will make
your copy
so much more persuasive right like for
example gym launch has
tons of one star reviews we also have
but we also have thousands of five stars
right and so the question is whether you
want to eat at a restaurant that has 4.7
you know stars with 3 000 ratings or you
would need at a place that has five
stars with 19
right i would rather you the 4.4.7 star
same thing would you buy on amazon right
because the damaging admissions the
reviews that are negative give credence
to the things that are positive
so let me give you a really famous
example that
viagra had and some of you guys may know
this commercial but it's literally
it it crushed for them right some of you
guys may remember that they had a
warning label
at the end of their advertisements that
said
if an election lasts longer than four
hours you know must contact
a medical uh you know professional right
and so the beauty is there was a genuine
risk
right but in making the risk they
amplified the power of the product every
single guy heard that warning and was
like i could have an erection for four
hours
like sign me up right and so it would be
like the same thing as saying like
um you know warning uh you know when you
sign up and start working with gymloc
you're gonna massively increase your tax
burden
all right so like like we we are not
liable for the amount of taxes that
you're gonna have to pay as a result of
the amount of money we're gonna make
right so it's it's the negative
consequence of the positive
that amplifies the believability of the
statement if we're warning people
that the extreme adverse effects of the
of the
of the result that we're promising in an
extreme fashion
then it makes the the the underlying
believability of whether or not
they're going to achieve it seem assumed
right
and then it makes the entire set of of
sentences or the preceding argument
um more uh persuasive right and
believable
and so ultimately um this is one of my
favorite persuasion tactics
and i love it because it's so based in
integrity right you're just saying
all of the things that someone is going
to find out eventually you might as well
use those things
to increase the persuasiveness of your
argument right
and so i wanted to leave this with you i
hope you found it valuable
keep keeping awesome try it in your copy
try it when you're presenting something
in a sales presentation and i guarantee
you
um you will have a prospect who believes
you much more and is more likely
likely to buy so lots of love and i'll
catch you on the flip side but